every 15 seconds another human being is
diagnosed with HIV one in seven
diagnosed with HIV are unaware of the
virus's presence
HIV is a lentivirus that causes acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome aids for short
this is a condition in humans that
causes progressive failure of the immune
system allowing life-threatening
opportunistic infections and cancers to
thrive at the molecular level HIV gains
access to the human helper t-cells by
binding to the cd4 receptor and ccr5
co-receptor
after entering the cell HIV uses a host
of enzymes successfully integrated
cinetic material within the human genome
inside the T helper cells then using the
cells own protein machinery an army of
new viral particles is produced in fact
so many that eventually the cell can no
longer hold all of them and burst open
current retroviral therapies for HIV
infections such as marabou rock rely on
competitive inhibition at the site of
the ccr5 co-receptor to effectively
limit the binding of HIV however deadly
infections as a result of an
immunocompromised system still occur
however in the search for a cure the
groundbreaking method uses a third party
adenovirus to edit the human genome with
its therapy a genetically engineered
adenovirus with the sequence for an HIV
neutralizing protein is used to infect a
muscle cell then like many viruses the
n-no viral DNA is integrated amongst the
human DNA sequence and this protein can
be naturally produced by human myocytes
through transcription and translation
this neutralizing molecule resembling an
antibody with the tail blocks both the
cd4 and ccr5 binding sites on HIV
rendering the virus useless and allowing
the human immune cells to take care of
the rest
currently the best treatment is
prevention so be sure to get tested if
suspected of having the infection for
more information about the structure of
ccr5 and other proteins be sure to visit
the protein databank website thank you
you